[موسيقى]
الجائحه الجائحه الى حدود اليوم لازلت
هناك بعض الاثار قائمه ومؤثره على
الاقتصاد الاوروبي فاقتصاد المراه بفتره
ركود حاده
سالبه جدا ولكن ما كانت او ما كانت
الاقتصاد يتعافى شيئا ما بعد مباشره بعد
الجائحه حتى تفجرت ازمه جديده
من خلال الاعمده بين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا
كان لديه ايضا اثر كبير في تازم او في
دخول مجموعه القطاعات الاقتصاديه المرتبطه
بالطاقه المرتبطه بالتجاره كذلك بصناعه
ايضا
في داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو ما فاقم
الازمه التي كانت مرتبطه بالركود
الاقتصادي وهو مع تقريبا كان سببا في
افلاس عدد من الشركات وفي تسريح عدد كبير
من العمال وفي دخول مجموعه من اقتصاديه
الاوروبيه في سياسات التقشفيه ثم لا ننسى
ايضا انه من اجل تسريع الخروج من التضخم
كانت هناك مجموعه من الاجراءات التي
اتخذتها البنوك المركزيه مثل رفع الفائده
المديريه وكذلك مساله الاحجامعه الزياده
في الاجور وهو ما كان له اثر سلبي على
ارتفاع نسب الفقره ان كانت بشكل طفيفي في
مجموعه من الدول ولكن كذلك بشكل كبير او
مشاكل الضغطا كبيرا على الانظمه
الاجتماعيه ولكن ايضا كان لديه اثر سلبي
على القدره الشرائيه للمواطن الاوروبيه
التي تراج
[موسيقى]
عت
هناك مجموعه من الارهاسات المرتبطه بتراجع
القدره الشرائيه
بالتراجع كذلك
الرفاهيه الرفاهيه الاوروبي ولكن الى حدود
الساعه هي نزلت في السياق المقبول
وبالتالي منصات ان نتحدث على ان هناك بلوغ
مستويات حاده من الفقر ولكن اذا استمرت
هذه الاوضاع دون ان يكون هناك تحسن لاداء
اقتصادي في اوروبا دون ان يكون هناك
استيعاب لموجات
البطاله سيكون التوجه نحو ارتفاع نسب
الفقر وهذه تاخذ اشكال اكثر حده
[موسيقى]
الى حدود الساعه يظل او يتوقع انه فقط
تراجع لحظي ضعفي مرتبطين الراهنتين وقد
تخرج منه اوروبا من السنوات المقبله حسب
هذه التقارير ولكن بالرغم من ذلك هناك
اشكال لهذا التراجع اصبحت اكثر حده في
مجموعه من الدول خاصه في اسبانيا وايطاليا
وبعض الدول المتوسطيه التي لا يمكن مقارنه
حجم ادائها الاقتصادي مع دول الشمال خاصه
بريطانيا والمانيا